so we are addicted to a certain way of
living we are addicted to living
permanently attached to our devices and
and often addicted to the stress and
burnout for me the first have changed
the first habit that I changed the
Keystone habit as is known in in habit
literature was sleep
I went from four to five hours sleep to
seven to eight hours sleep and that
transformed my life truly and now of
course we have conclusive scientific
findings that sleep is really a miracle
drug improves our health and strengthens
our immune system improves our mental
clarity and makes us more joyful in our
daily lives and I recommend that we
start simply by adding 30 minutes to how
much sleep we are getting I think
everybody can do that and people who say
they can't do that I think need to look
at how much time do they spend watching
house of cards or staying up to watch
Jon Stewart or anything like that you
know have a lot more discretionary time
than we think
meditation is another step that I
recommend and I recommend starting with
five minutes and and recognizing that
thoughts will keep coming and but what
meditation teaches us is to not attach
ourselves to our thoughts and to find
some stillness beyond the thoughts and I
don't see meditation as one more thing
to put on our to-do list meditation does
us it's something that enhances the
quality of the rest of our day simply by
connecting us to that place in us that
Center that every religion and many
philosophers and scientists have talked
about using different language which is
the play
of wisdom strength and peace in us the
place that Archimedes the Greek
mathematician referred to when he said
give me a place to stand and I can move
the world well the great thing about
introducing mindfulness and meditation
into our lives is that it does make it
easier for us to unplug from our day and
actually go to sleep and having some
rituals a little transition periods
could be just ten minutes between our
day life and and actually going to sleep
is incredibly helpful
I have such rituals that I recommend in
the book like having a hot bath or
shower to kind of wash the day away
making sure as I do that my bedroom is a
device free zone I don't take my smart
phones to bed I don't even take my
Kindle or my iPad to bed I just read
real books in bed and I prefer to read
books that are not related to work you
know like poetry or philosophy or novels
and as we learn through meditation for
example to steal our mind and it becomes
easier for us to be able to go to sleep
you